hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí a américa este es el
espacio de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
empezamos en el norte porque el
presidente de méxico andrés manuel lópez
obrador visitó washington esta semana
para reunirse con su homólogo
estadounidense joe biden una cita para
buscar acuerdos pero que tuvo en lugar
después del boicot e iniciado por el
mandatario de mexico a la cumbre de las
américas que se celebró en junio en los
ángeles vamos a ciudad de mexico y
bajamos a centroamérica panamá donde el
presidente de laurentino cortizo
enfrenta a una ola de protestas que
inició en contra del alza del precio de
los combustibles pero que derivó en un
reclamo por mayor cubrimiento de salud y
educación y para que atienda el problema
del desempleo nos lo cuenta nuestro
corresponsal
y visitamos el sur del continente perú
donde el cáncer es la segunda causa de
muerte después del coi
1935 mil personas perdieron la vida en
2021 por esa enfermedad una cifra que
creció precisamente por las demoras en
los tratamientos y cirugías surgidos
durante la pandemia les contamos desde
lima
[Música]
y vamos de inmediato a hablar de la
visita a washington del presidente de
méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador que
recordemos no visitó eeuu en junio
cuando fue invitado a la cumbre de las
américas por parte de joe biden en
rechazo a la decisión del presidente
anfitrión de no invitar a los
representantes de cuba nicaragua ni
venezuela por sus prácticas
antidemocráticas pero si visitó la casa
blanca esta semana para reunirse con el
mandatario estadounidense tras ese
desaire que fue seguido por otros países
amlo llegó con una serie de propuestas a
la casa blanca incluyendo descuentos en
el precio de la gasolina para los
estadounidenses que viven en la frontera
y acceso a visas para los empleados
agrícolas con el fin de suplir la
escasez de mano de obra en la unión
americana
una cita que busco mostrar las buenas
relaciones entre las dos naciones
vecinas del norte del continente pero yo
logro vamos a ciudad de mexico con
nuestro corresponsal maria carbonell
mario cuáles fueron los avances
concretos de este encuentro así es el
presidente de lópez obrador se ha
mostrado satisfecho no solamente de su
encuentro con joe biden quien dijo en
todo momento tuvo una actitud de respeto
sino también de su reunión con los
empresarios estadounidenses quienes
asegura están muy contentos y han
entendido de qué se trata su política
energética no obstante esto contrasta
con la postura expresada por los
integrantes de la cámara de comercio de
eeuu quienes a través de un comunicado
externaron su seria preocupación por el
deterioro del clima de inversiones en
mexico y llaman al gobierno a cumplir
con los compromisos establecidos en el
tema en el acuerdo de libre comercio
concretamente piden erradicar las
políticas del sector energético que
favorecen consideran injustamente a las
empresas estatales
otro punto de cierta controversia es el
ofrecimiento de lópez obrador a los
estadounidenses de que vengan a cargar
sus tanques de gasolina a mexico donde
es más barata esto ha provocado
señalamientos en el sentido de que si en
efecto es más barata pero porque le está
costando mucho dinero al gobierno
mexicano que está destinando hasta 20
mil millones de dólares para subsidiar
las gasolinas y así contener la
inflación un punto más de cierta
polémica es el tema de las visas lópez
obrador dijo que fue aceptado a su
propuesta de incrementar el número de
visas temporales de trabajo para
mexicanos y centroamericanos y si bien
el propio joe biden dijo que su objetivo
es aumentar la cantidad de estos
permisos temporales lo cierto es que no
hay una cantidad específica que se haya
comprometido es decir no hay un número
exacto de cuántas visas se van a crear
sin embargo bueno en términos generales
lópez obrador ha calificado como muy
buena su visita a washington y que
continuará la cooperación permanente
mario carbon el corresponsal de france
24 en ciudad de méxico gracias por la
información y cambiamos de tema pero
seguimos en eeuu el servicio secreto
borro mensajes de texto de sus agentes
que fueron enviados durante la toma al
capitolio del 6 de enero de 2021 los
mensajes podrían ser cruciales para las
investigaciones de la cámara de
representantes y del departamento de
justicia sobre si donald trump y sus
asesores cercanos alentaron la
insurrección de sus seguidores al
capitolio estadounidense mientras los
congresistas certificaban la victoria de
joe biden en las elecciones
entretanto en una polémica declaración
en el marco de una entrevista con cnn
sobre precisamente el asalto al
capitolio john bolton el ex asesor de
seguridad nacional durante la
administración de donald trump y que
también fue embajador de eeuu ante la
onu durante el gobierno de george w.bush
admitió haber organizado golpes de
estado en otras naciones escuchemos
no es un ataque a nuestra democracia es
donald trump actuando en su propio
beneficio es algo que ocurrió una sola
vez en la vida
con todo el respeto no sé si estoy de
acuerdo con usted para ser justos no
tiene que ser brillante para intentar
dar un golpe de estado se siente que no
estoy de acuerdo como alguien que ha
ayudado a planear golpes de estado nano
aquí ya sabes en otros lugares requiere
mucho trabajo y eso no es lo que hizo
trump sólo iba a ciegas de una idea a
otra en última instancia si impulso a
los amotinados a ir al capitolio esto no
ayuda
bolton también ocupó altos cargos en las
administraciones de ronald reagan y bush
padre y sigamos en eeuu pero vamos a
california donde los bomberos trabajan
contrareloj para contener un incendio
forestal en el parque nacional yosemite
y las llamas amenazan árboles milenarios
veamos más en el siguiente informe
con más de 64 metros de alto y 3000 años
de edad
el gigante oso pardo es uno de los más
longevos y antiguos árboles del mundo
y mientras un incendio forestal se le
acerca al sequoia gigante los aspersores
toman su lugar el incendio está cerca de
las secuoyas tenemos una línea de
incendio alrededor de todo mariposa
grove está un poco cerca del fuego
terrestre ningún árbol seco ya ha sido
dañado ha sido bautizado como el
incendio washington y ha quemado varios
kilómetros cuadrados del parque nacional
yosemite y el gigante oso pardo es solo
uno de los más de 500 secuoyas maduros
bajo amenaza en lo que se conoce como el
mariposa groove cientos de bomberos han
estado luchando contra el incendio desde
que comenzó el 7 de julio y usan
imágenes de drones infrarrojos para
monitorear que tanto se acerca el fuego
a los famosos árboles
el más grande es de 2.000 metros
cuadrados vamos a estar allí reforzando
los volando drones infrarrojos hoy
verificando si hay más y esta es una de
las principales prioridades hoy para
contener el fuego al exlíder autopista
41 los árboles gigantes tienen su propia
protección sus ramas altas y corteza
gruesa y los expertos dicen que el fuego
moderado puede incluso ayudarlos a
reproducirse quemando conos y liberando
semillas en el suelo
pero a medida que el fuego se sale de
control la preocupación crece tanto por
los árboles como por las personas que
viven en el camino del fuego el pequeño
pueblo de guayana dentro del parque fue
evacuado y la parte sur de yosemite ha
sido cerrada para los visitantes
mientras que el resto permanece abierto
vamos ahora a panamá donde el presidente
de laurentino cortizo instaló una mesa
de diálogo con miras a desactivar el
movimiento de protesta en su contra que
inició en rechazo al aumento del precio
de los combustibles en el país
centroamericano que ha alcanzado el 40%
en los últimos seis meses y que es un
fenómeno global pero en el caso de
panamá se amplió la exigencia en contra
de las deficiencias en los sistemas de
salud y de educación y por la tasa de
desempleo nuestro corresponsal oscar
sulbarán nos retrata quiénes son los
panameños que están protestando y por
qué
el cacique de la comarca kuna ha
decidido salir a las calles en la ciudad
de panamá en representación de los
pueblos indígenas la razón de su
protesta se debe al alto costo del
combustible y los alimentos y a la
defensa de su territorio
estamos siguiendo al gobierno la
demarcación crítica a las comarcas que
le hace falta de los hermanos
originarios del país también estamos
pidiendo el desalojo de todos los
colonos instalados en nuestras comarcas
las invasiones que se veãa diariamente
en nuestros territorios
pero no solo los indígenas están bien
conformes desde el sector público de la
salud reclaman un sistema apto para
atender a los panameños
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sin corrupción
[Aplausos]
esta todavía logra gracias
a
las protestas iniciadas por los
educadores por el alto costo de la vida
han tenido como respuesta por parte del
ejecutivo el congelamiento del precio
del combustible el control de precios
para una serie de productos y medidas de
austeridad pero para los manifestantes
aún sigue siendo insuficiente es
necesario y urgente darle a nuestro
estudiante lo que se merecen por la
constitución ningún gobierno quiere
cumplir eso ha sido una esperanza hay
una bandera de más de 25 años y hasta el
momento señor presidente nito cortizo el
momento ahora el gobierno panameño por
ahora está en una situación difícil
maniobrando con las peticiones y
reclamos de los distintos sectores pero
además sin dinero porque la deuda
pública se ha incrementado en al menos
50 a 300 y supera los 40 mil millones de
dólares
en perú los pacientes de cáncer
denuncian que tras la pandemia del coi
19 la atención médica se hizo precaria
para ellos el sistema de salud estatal
quedó saturado y muchos acudieron a
establecimientos privados y ahora están
endeudados nuestro corresponsal en lima
francisco zacarías muestra de su
historia
amanda quispe vive un múltiple drama su
hijo tiene cáncer y no recibió
tratamiento oportuno ahora sufre
convulsiones ha perdido la vista y la
memoria como el sistema sanitario
estatal quedó saturado amanda lo interno
en una clínica para salvar su vida hoy
debe más de 127 mil dólares y les dan
por embargar la casa sentimos que son
más discriminados no sentimos que hemos
discriminada nos hemos escuchado y así
como mi niña y un montón de niños y hay
otros que ya no están con nosotros nos
han partido ya han fallecido por por
estar más la atención también en perú
las enfermedades neoplásicas son la
segunda causa de muerte en el país según
cifras oficiales 70.000 nuevos casos se
registran cada año en el mismo período
35.000 peruanos han fallecido por cáncer
la defensoría del pueblo denuncia
escasez de medicamentos y demoras en
tratamientos y cirugías alejandro
escobar paciente con cáncer de próstata
demanda una buena atención en salud si
quisiera que haga por lo menos unos tres
hospitales iguales para poder conservar
a todos nuestros hermanos
que estamos mal
yo quiera
cante que
es el ministerio de salud reconoce
deficiencias en atención debido a la
pandemia del cob y 19 el gobierno ha
dispuesto presupuesto para mejorar los
servicios oncológicos sin embargo no
habrá solución a la crisis en el corto
plazo nos va a tomar
aproximadamente 78 años para poder
llegar a los estadios precor y recién en
el año 2030 podremos predecir que
estamos llegando a los escenarios
prepandémica amanda aquí este también
exige que las autoridades atiendan sus
reclamos para evitar la muerte de su
hijo en perú 175 mil personas esperan la
implementación de la ley nacional del
cáncer que garantice cobertura universal
y oportuna
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
a giovanni agudelo pueden ver esta
emisión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom por favor
envíen me sus comentarios y opiniones a
la dirección que ven en sus pantallas
para más información de nuestro
continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]